we've only started like we're quite
early in the course still so the stuff
that you've seen on the reference sheet
you're mostly having in using very much
because you don't know most of it let's
just have a quick browse through and I
want you to I wonder if you remember how
many of you looked at the reference
sheet three pages right
two of the pages are two unit two pages
for two unit and the third page then is
three extension one right that's
convenient
now let's just have a look to it and see
how much of this at this point now we
recognize okay I am going to bring this
down okay
here we go advocate you can see if it's
up at the zoom back a little bit I have
the gate you can see algebra stuff like
first topic of the year and what I'm a
polygon is in there as well equation of
a circle we haven't dealt with this this
year but you actually know those at the
end of you can okay this is the cordage
rhetorical point then you see a whole
bunch of trig over here I pointed this
out before that you've got these
identities here you've got the Hayley
little pipe recording identity there
there are two versions of the plastic or
you identity why did I only include this
one is it reliable because you can get
all the other ones from here right if
you remember or if you refer to this
this is your guide and we don't need to
include the rest of them for example if
you wanted the one that has 10 squared
in us what would you do to this yeah
yeah you divide through by actually
dividing by Colin is not quite enough I
need to write like on squared everything
is squared so now we're tied into tan
squared plus + 1 equals cot cot twin
consecrate turquoise with a mobile
phones and then be sick sweat okay
that's fine
I would add this stuff what's this book
this is so that if you see sign 50
degrees you should immediately think
route read or to write like that should
just be instinctive to you these used to
be the first thing that I would draw on
my paper when I'm not them in my
advanced this us again see the new
encountered last year when you were
doing trig in you're measuring with
triangles let me come back up to here
now how look we're in quite a geometry
land at the moment what are this do you
recognize you recognize all of that do
you know what this man this guy you
don't watch with him before birthday
we're going to encounter this a little
bit later on okay because they're
distance between two points when you've
got two points unambiguously if you say
the distance between them it's like
locating the interval that joins them
that's the distance but if you say a
point and a line it's not so good here's
what he's a line if I say the distance
right do I mean like walking along this
way or that way in order to make sure
that we can communicate this in a way
that resists that we say the
perpendicular distance which is also the
shortest distance okay we'll come to
this later on improving where this sweet
or horizontal distance there's gradient
there's a line for which we're going to
have a look at later this lesson
actually there's a little asset sugar
like there's a line right there you
learn three forms you know them really
well to do with two points in dormitory
what's the missing one you've got get it
she got gradient
think back yesterday there's a midpoint
formula no big point formal there is a
midpoint point remember I said when we
said we go to this trick stuff here we
include the choose up we don't include
any of the other ones that come out of
this because you can get to them from
here okay the midpoint folder is on the
sheet it's just that it's high
on this extension one page again let's
have a look down and see if we can
recognize stuff we've done all this
right this is really bells yes so
they're just a regular expansion there's
your tea results right there that's
convenient we have to go to this yet
there'll be a time but there aren't you
have a guess
okay now there's a couple of things to
point out firstly I already said to you
there's a midpoint formula on the sheet
there it is
do you recognize it um the midpoint of
that interval is you take an interval
and you divide it into a given ratio
what reshoot is the midpoint divided
into one to one they're the same marker
and used come and train with just a
little work with that right well if the
ratio is one to one look at all the MS
and ends right what happens if you
change all of those into ones you get
you get an x1 plus x2 on to and then you
get y1 plus y2 on does that's the
midpoint formula so it is there just
like sine square plus cos square equals
one you can get to it from there if you
like now I actually want you to turn to
your book where you did your work
yesterday you wrote down a formula for
an internal division of an interval but
it wasn't this one the one mr. Dennis
came to you was one which is very
commonly used Euler's it relies on you
10 and 11 and the textbook also use it
it uses different letters and it uses a
different thought off can you look and
see the difference I'm pretty sure my
memory serves yes the form is you wrote
of you okay I think the form you wrote
it in was like this
that looks good yes and then of course
the wise up you know the same thing but
wise okay so have a look this is tricky
because unlike say our web scroll bar
you guys know it well enough unlike the
distance formula and the gradient
formula and the midpoint formula it
doesn't matter really where you put your
x ones in your attitudes but here it
matters a lot
you get a whole different point if you
swap these things around right so what
you notice okay the way that this has
been written is to make the comparison
with midpoint formula a little bit
easier right you see it x1 x2 so you
have your points in order the upshot of
that is have a look at the ratios on the
top they're not a mr. des mannes exact
point they're not in alphabetical order
he knows that and that matters how are
they elected to rate at this time
what's different they are elected to try
and make it memorable by making these
match CDs but the option of that is well
if you have this in alphabetical order
unlike us you have to swap around does
that make sense now I will leave it up
to you which you prefer I mean I have a
preference for that one but that's
because that's the one that I learnt
from ages ago so that's just where my
brain defaults I do also like the fact
that they don't use em could be quality
auditory em mean something significant
all the time mainly great yet so that's
why I tend to avoid but what I want you
to avoid is being confusing me again
because you have two different folders
in your head but conflicts with each
other okay if you're going to rely on
this thing then you wants you like
predict ahead of time okay am I going to
use this form there form or the one that
I've learned is that form you prefer
Sally Fitz